alright this is gonna be a Kaiser report
take one action that's right we're in
Los Angeles Stacy the part of Max Keiser
will be played by his stunt double
slacks miser flex miser is a big
troublemaker in fact max we are in
Hollywood if it weren't so smoggy
you would be able to see the Hollywood
sign up there but of course this being
Los Angeles it is filled with smog so
you don't see the Hollywood sign
CGI a CGI in Hollywood actually there
has been like record levels of smog at
the moment so I'm fairness everywhere in
the world is having record levels of of
everything whether it's record high
temperatures low temperatures all-time
highs and stock markets all-time lows
and in interest rates Stan Druckenmiller
billionaire hedge fund manager he was
out saying that massive debt fuel in the
next financial crisis so he sees the
record levels of debt just like the
record levels of smog and climate change
and heat and exhaust and carbon
emissions and all that sort of stuff
everything is at peak everything the
extremism in every possible category
were at the extreme Earth's carrying
capacity for human beings has reached
its limit the stock market trading at
all-time highs the debt load peak
everywhere as we head to two hundred
fifty three hundred fifty five hundred
percent debt to GDP this is a planet on
the verge of a major tsunami of debt and
wipeout in catastrophic nightmarish
behavior this is our like a bit of
brinksmanship going on everybody is kind
of like it's kind of exhilarating to
look at how much debt we could pile on
how much carbon dioxide pile into there
how much smog we can put in there how
many people we could put into one city
how much prices can rise in the property
market stock markets and stuff and
another brinkmanship story that happened
on our way out here to Los Angeles we
have pre recorded an interview with
Mitch Firestein of Planet Ponzi calm and
it was funny because he said that Elon
Musk of Tesla was guilty of securities
fraud and lo and behold like two or
three days later of course the SEC has
sued him for securities fraud partly
brinkmanship because Elon Musk was
negotiating with them and he decided he
wanted to just be challenged them you
know I was talking to Johnny Depp last
night in the Viper Room and you know
Elon is a friend and he's really taking
capitalism to that extreme that it needs
to go to express the people zeitgeist in
terms of the representation of equity in
our inner being and I talked it you know
Johnny in his next role he wants me to
be in Pirates of the Caribbean part 9
and I'm gonna possibly consider it this
is all gonna be taking place on Wall
Street the Pirates on Wall Streets gonna
be called I'm riding the script just so
you know the last time Max lived here
was like 2000 and that's why Johnny Depp
was huge back then and the Viper Room
existed Johnny Depp is actually gonna be
playing Matthew melon one where the
rumors is in a film so he's a crypto guy
and it was a friend of Kaiser report
until he passed away but I also want to
talk about the brinksmanship that's in
the headlines this week let's talk about
real financial news max and some
economic stuff happening in the real
world this is not fiction this is not
fake news
agricultural exports plunge Trump
accuses China of meddling in US
elections so the trade deficit widened
by 5.3 percent and all just despite I
guess because of the trade war
agricultural exports were down nine
point five percent from July and a
whopping 15 point 2 percent since June
now the interesting thing is that China
or the China daily which is the Chinese
you know government you know news outlet
they took out a four-page ad spread in
Iowa basically telling the Iowa farmers
that is because of Trump's dual you know
his his war his trade war with China
that their exports have plunged right so
I guess following up on what we've been
saying the last few weeks the three
merges of mercantilism so what does that
mean in other words post the past
mercantilist period of the 19th century
we went into more of a monetarist global
economy run by central banks and they
were able to exert influence by
adjusting interest rates and by printing
money but now we're at a new neo
mercantilist period so the fact that
China's taking out ads in an Iowa
newspaper is reflective of that
it's gonna be more trade for trade basis
without the kind of influence that
central banks have because central banks
are not really in a position now
according to Trump this is really
trumpism this is Trump's economic model
he wants to get rid of globalization is
that the UN he's saying I want to take
us out of all globalized institutions we
just wanted to go trade would go
bilateral we want to do individual deals
and so something like that reflects this
because China is saying you know what we
have to come up with new strategies to
exert our influence in the global trade
so ticking ads out in an Iowa newspaper
whereas they used to maybe adjust
interest rates or remove the when their
currency down you see that that's now
that's the passe that's not really in
keeping with today's new neo
mercantilist model and I don't see the
problem with taking this to the people
letting the because we are in a
globalized world a hyper globalized
world that the farmer in Iowa is selling
to people all over the world consumers
all over the world not just in Iowa so
Donald Trump tweeted about these these
ads taken out in the Des Moines Register
he said China is actually placing
propaganda ads in the Des Moines
Register and other papers made to look
like news that's because we are beating
them on trade opening markets and the
farmers will make a fortune when this is
over I think you know just take it to
the people and let them decide and let
them hear both sides of the story and
find out what's going on I totally moved
that if I said price precedes news and
fig prices perceived thickness the
problem with monster ISM is the end up
with fake prices and you ended up with a
glut of fake news but if this is real
O'Neill mercantilism we're gonna go back
to real prices in real news so I think
it's a reversion to the mean of trade
has just really been going on in the
planet Earth now for a thousands of
years
I want to next move on to the latest Fed
you know raising the rates by 25 basis
points and Chairman Jerome Powell spoke
afterward and there was one thing that I
picked up on in terms of something that
you and I have noted over the past few
years certainly leading into the 2016
election when Obamacare prices soared
and how that might have impacted the
electoral system
the electoral vote of course that has
not been discussed because in you know
we all know what has happened to cable
news and the mainstream media here since
the 2016 election they've basically
become days of our lives or General
Hospital or some sort of soap opera and
it's nothing gets discussed but here
drone Pao points out something quite
interesting the feds not backing off
pals standouts and zingers at the press
conference asked if fiscal policy the
ballooning deficit after tax cuts and
spending increases comes up a lot at
FOMC meetings Jerome Powell said because
he was asked about fiscal policy and he
said it doesn't really come up it's not
really our job we don't have
responsibility for fiscal policy but in
the longer run fiscal policy will have a
significant impact on the economy it's
no secret it's been true for a long time
that with our uniquely expensive health
care delivery system and the aging of
our population we fund on an
unsustainable fiscal path for a long
time so he's saying our economy the
United States economy is on an
unsustainable path due to health care
costs do you see this discussed and it
you would think that the fact that the
u.s. is on an unsustainable path would
warrant deep conversation on Fox on
MSNBC on CNN on the mean news channels
here that what do we do about this how
do we stop this unsustainable path how
do we stop these health poor health care
expenses what do we do but we don't see
that conversation ever happening on the
news here which is why you have Kaiser
report well yeah I mean I think you're
right to cite this phrase unsustainable
path as an interesting phrase coming out
of the central bank because their job is
to cheerlead the economy and to always
talk about the optimistic future and to
never mention any negatives whatsoever
that's the new role of the Fed so to
talk about an unsustainable path is
remarkable in that regard and it's
interesting that he lumps healthcare in
with fiscal policy therefore
legitimizing the idea that Obama care is
a tax it is a tax
it's an unauthorized tax and the
corporation's of America under the
Constitution it's not illegal for them
to impose a tax on Americans but it's
more than just that it's the entire
healthcare system you saying even people
who have a job at some corporation and
the corporation provides you with
healthcare that is not Obamacare because
this next headline also shows you know
one of the problems that has happened in
America and why we have two thousand and
two thousand and one crash why we have
the 2007 to 2009 crash why we have this
upcoming massive debt fueled financial
crisis 10 Druckenmiller says it is part
of the reason is that incomes have not
been going up America's 20 year shift
people are getting paid less in cash
wages salaries and more in benefits in
large part because our health care
system is still so expensive so over the
past 20 years companies and governments
have been paying their employees more in
benefits and less in cash wages and
salaries and that's especially the case
among people who work in the highly
unionized public sector the big picture
of all the different types of benefits
the cost of health insurance has
consumed the most of the average workers
compensation representing 8.2 percent of
$1 in pay today versus 5.8 cents of a
dollar in 1998 that's because the UF
health health care system is so
expensive right so they're training cash
for benefits and the problem there is
that I can't convert my benefits into
gold with hard money and savings so I
don't have no economic sovereignty yes
they don't want me to give me any cash
because I would put some of that cash
into gold and I would have economic
sovereignty and financial independence
but that is to be shunned at every every
every step of the way because we are to
be beholden and we are to be enslaved by
the system well health care eight-year
raise is what they said because a lot of
people have said where has all this
productivity gone a lot of it has been
captured by shareholders and the CEO
class and the executive class but the
fact is that it's also being captured by
the health industry that which is part
of the fire sector the finance insurance
and
the state so is capturing all your gains
but that doesn't get accumulated you
know if we spend $12,000 a year each on
an Obamacare health insurance policy
it's not like that's saved for us is
that doesn't it just disappears into the
pockets of the healthcare executives
it's extortion it's essentially
extortion they should change fire
economy the hell fire because you needed
to eighths for health care health
finance insurance and real estate that's
the new economy now fire
absolutely and that's what we've covered
this pretty extensively and that the the
integrity of the economy is being
undermined by the Geico nian and Larson
istic behavior of this oligopoly
shakedown economy Storting every chance
they get without any pushback by
Congress you know Congress is involved
in other genetic ins and they actually
do anything worthwhile and in the last
30 seconds here max I want to say that
in fact our Obamacare premiums are going
down next year that was a shock and
partly because they had jacked up the
prices so so high in the last two years
so they made too much profit and they
have to lower that because they can't
spend it all every shyster in Times
Square with the three-card Monte knows
you got to let the mark win a couple of
bucks on the way out so they don't stab
me in the neck well we'll be back with a
lot more fun and games here in Hollywood
right after this break so don't go away
welcome back to the Kaiser report on Max
Keiser time now to turn to Michael
Turpin of Coyne agenda bit angels and
transform dot P R Michael welcome back
transform group nice to see a form group
I take it the dot PR is Puerto Rico it
is and that's our URL ok Michael Turpin
thanks for coming on big story here he
wanted to get into it okay you recently
have twenty five million dollars worth
of crypto assets stolen from you and
your wife tell us exactly what happened
how did it happen walk us through the
crime so there has unfortunately been a
big issue it's over a billion dollars
now in counting where the major
telephone companies they don't tell you
that there's extra levels of protection
available and then when you ask for them
they're uneven and how they implement
them t-mobile for example I got hacked
twice last year lost a very small amount
and went and said what's the best level
of protection you can give and they all
say they have these kind of secret
celebrity accounts if you ask for them
and they will give you a six to eight
digit PIN that they say no one else can
change in t-mobile's case they also go
and put a do not port eighteen t will
not do that I don't know why it wouldn't
do that but they don't and I still felt
pretty secure when they said you're safe
now you have this six digit no one can
change it so go through the porting
crime like how does that work
sure so how how Sims acting is what I
like to call it because porting sounds
difficult and swapping sounds like you
have a little party and swapping phones
but now with sim jacking what happens is
somebody in the in the earlier version
someone would actually go into a store
pretend to be you have a fake ID and
then say they're you and hey I lost my
phone and then they would go and and
give it to their phone and as soon as
they had that they had your digital life
they had your digital identity and
that's how in the earlier days about two
or three years ago some people were
losing thousands of bitcoins because
they would then get in there they'd
reset passwords because most gmail
accounts email accounts all sorts of
software exchanges before Google to a
fake kind of became popular would be the
way that you prove you were you well if
you give away without your permission
your digital identity that proves your
allegedly you
then they can go and take everything
that relies on that right so yeah 25
million in crypto assets held at where
were they where were these things these
were not in exchange accounts I actually
had all those protected they're either
in bank vaults they're in treasures and
logistics in in this you know safe
deposit boxes my exchanges all have to
if a my Gmail us too if a but as you
know transform group we have a PR
division we work with over 100 digital
currency companies sometimes they pay us
a digital currency sometimes these are
things that are not ERC 20 tokens in
theory of assets and they have their own
native wallets staking wallets that you
have to have it on that so these are
still things that I have private keys
that are in you know encrypted accounts
or sorry encrypted files but there are
ways if the right hacker gets in and
they can find little little hints they
can find something you cut and paste in
something and it got auto saved into an
invisible file or in a hidden file
that's kind of what they found because
again nothing would have happened had
AT&T after telling me that I was secure
with having this six digit a you know
safety code what they didn't say was
that anybody at AT&T can do a manual
override and that's what happened is
there any thought that there for lack of
a better phrase was an inside job
absolutely because that's what I would
say is phase two of what's going on now
there were arrests in almost every case
involving AT&T in the FBI investigations
where I guess the the the the criminal
gangs have decided that it's too much
work getting a homeless guy to come in
and pretend they're you and pay a
hundred bucks to the CV can trick
somebody why not go direct to the source
so they're actually going in through
social media approaching people who have
AT&T on their profile knowing that they
don't have the dude out port and then
say hey you want to make a little money
and they pay them a Bitcoin we believe
that's what happened here the gentleman
was named in the complaint Jamil Smith
and the in the Norwich Connecticut store
19 you know has had criminal record and
since then has also been arrested for
larceny so you know
not somebody that you should give the
ability without checking with a superior
to override your special protection it'd
be the equivalent maxes if you went into
the airport with your thing got past TSA
and all of a sudden didn't work and they
said oh that's fine we'll just override
it you are in fact suing 18 t that's
prepared a huge number out there like
for a big number it is in federal court
jury trial and so the actual amount of
the loss was in the twenty two and a
half million dollar range these were all
poins they had the good ordered att's
case the bad fortune to steal them on
the absolute high day of altcoin value
that's the day that Bitcoin though the
markets had an eight hundred billion
dollar mark so the particular tokens
that were stolen had close to their
all-time highs but that's the value when
they were stolen that's the value that
they then were able to suck out of
exchanges and turn into bitcoins which
were then presumably turned into cash
this sim hacking has been around for a
while now these there's been an attack
vector in the phone business for quite
some time but I'm wondering why have
they been dragging their feet for so
long is it just left RG on their part
that it's crazy because I mean at least
t-mobile you know now has a do not port
function this could be stopped
immediately if all the carriers simply
allowed you to say do that port and it
took you know several levels of effort
to be able to support like you had to go
in and and a superior had to approve it
that's not what it is right now right so
like with credit you know you can lock
down your credit for any theft right
let's pray services it says they go
through a process and so identity theft
is thwarted in this way but the phone
companies don't have that in place that
AT&T certainly doesn't right so they
could be moving to something like that
are there any others joining in the suit
with you right now it is just me I've
gotten contacted by many many people who
lost amounts in in some cases close to
what I lost in one case actually more if
you count the high value of Bitcoin
because they got thousands stolen in a
similar hack back when Bitcoin was worth
less but this is not a class-action suit
first of all AT&T prohibits in there
contract that you basically take it or
leave it to participate in a
class-action suit they also prohibit you
from suing them for any reason
whatsoever including their own fraud and
their own gross negligence we believe
that's a weaker claim the class-action
to get that thrown out would probably be
a different set of circumstances than to
get a judge which has actually happened
in the case in a different instance not
involving sim jacking where a judge was
able to say this is an unconscionable
part of the contract later that end up
getting reinstated for that case but we
believe that this is an important
precedent that you can't just go in and
have the ability to have a phone or not
have a phone rest on you basically
saying that AT&T can do absolutely
anything and you have to indemnify them
for their bad behavior and you cannot
under any circumstances have a jury
trial for gross negligence and fraud so
the encrypted community I would think
would be behind this because the entire
community is exposed I haven't actually
seen a lot of coverage on this is it
it's is it something where are we in
that is it getting coverage what's going
on well I counted we had about a billion
impressions of coverage the first three
or four days I'm in the PR business so I
know how to break stories I I let
Reuters breaking globally and then I got
picked up by a lot of other outlets and
by and large has been very sympathetic
and supportive coverage every now and
then you'll get a social media group
saying well it's coin bases fault he
should have secured the business the bit
points better there were no bitcoins and
I don't have a point base account again
it was just it was native and staking
wallets of course 21 million bitcoins
will be created and when it's all done
there's 18 million or so currently in
circulation they estimate that up to 7
million have been lost yes in this
similar circumstance is going back to
2009 that's a remarkable number that's
30% of total
completely lost well and again lost and
stolen or two different things because
if they're stolen they're still around
and somebody has them they may have sold
the cash and then somebody else has them
and somebody's holding that Bitcoin
right now if they were if they were Sims
Act
on the lost part a lot of those come to
the first ten million that you know
happened in the first four years a
Bitcoin before the first having and
waltz we're not very secure back then
people would go and mind them just keep
on their hard drive the hard drive would
crash they wouldn't have it and Boop's I
lost 10,000 bitcoins which back that
were worth about 10 bucks so you've been
in this business really since its
inception I would say you know it's gone
through all kinds of growth and we're at
a level now where it's getting
international attention international
regulations are coming in you of course
are in Puerto Rico where you believe
that the regulatory environment there is
quite friendly the tax treatment is
quite friendly but there are other
territories competing to be you know
crypto Switzerland so to speak I think
Malta is making a big move can you give
us an update on that sure what's
happening to Puerto Rico and globally
where is the sweet spot if you will
jurisdictionally for crypto there is
sort of a competition going on now to
see who can be the friend list of
smaller nations typically that want the
business and then obviously there's
places like India and China that are
saying no we don't want anything crypto
because we don't understand it and we
think it's just drugs and terrorism I
think you know look China still doesn't
have Facebook and Google legal so
they're not a good model to say what the
future is going to be we held the quaint
agenda Europe this summer our second one
in Malta we had the Prime Minister come
and deliver the opening keynote so that
was a pretty strong statement they have
a prime minister of a you know of a
nation to come in and go to a crypto
investor conference and Puerto Rico the
government is are they so warming
warming to this presence of the crypto
you know billionaires as they're called
yeah you know I mean it's it's been
mixed coverage of the media I think
which is just quite frankly because
there's a very small party called the
independence party
it's about 3% of the vote but they don't
want anybody American they're they they
go and march in front of the Vanderbilt
and say Yankee go home and you know that
that that's unfortunately been sort of
the loudest voice whenever they ask for
an opinion from the other side both of
the major parties have been very
supportive both the the party that
that voted it in in fact former
Secretary of academic development
Alberto Paco is gonna be a keynote at
our coin agenda global event in Las
Vegas October 23rd to 25th right after
money 2020 and so I believe that Puerto
Rico has a unique opportunity to be a
leader they were kind of waiting for the
Wyoming bill to be passed and I'm still
a proponent that they need to kind of
copy and paste what Wyoming is done
Katelyn long who started that'll also be
a keynote speaker and that's where the
states say we have the rights and I
think it's even mortified in the
territory to basically say we want this
here now you are big in the ICL space
the initial coin already mentioned
tokens get tokens here and and that
certainly had a tumultuous year in the
past year what were we with the ICL
business so right now America has been
very I wouldn't say unfriendly but
they've been unkind they are not letting
you know what the regulations are
basically the SEC is kind of going in
you know making individual statements
then putting out statements saying this
only speaking for me and not for the
other members of the SEC so if you look
at SDC that gov there are no rules
there's simply interpretations of
lawyers and most of them particularly in
the Bay Area in New York are very
conservative so that's scaring away a
business that started really in America
to offshore so right now in general most
of my clients are going and they may
have an operating company that's a
Delaware corporate or eco Corp and and
then do their actual crowd sale in
Cayman BVI Barbados one of the Caribbean
countries if you're in North American
Asian spot hub has been Singapore what's
your next event coming up our next event
is quite agenda global October 23rd to
25th at Mandalay Bay perfect Michael
Turpin thanks for being on the Kaiser
report thank you that's gonna do it for
this edition of the Kaiser report with
me max guys all right a server like I
think our guest Michael Turpin of Coyne
agenda bit angels and transform group
dot PR if you want to catch us on
Twitter it's guys report until next time
bye y'all
[Music]